foreign
the pandemic caused worldwide damage
economically socially and of course to
People's Health
but some communities have actually come
out of it stronger
welcome to the covid-19 special
in a poor part of the Venezuelan Capital
Caracas some neighbors had the bright
idea of opening a cinema at a great
height
was so successful that it's still
running after the lockdowns
[Music]
Uganda to accompany a blind man as he
goes about his everyday routines during
the pandemic restrictions on public Life
Hit disabled people particularly hard
but first to Germany
in the town of Marburg a medical team is
researching the effects of long covid
including ailments apparently caused by
vaccinations demand at the clinic is
high
[Music]
a small town in the western German state
of hessen in this Adil is one of
Germany's few treatment centers for
people suffering suspected adverse
reactions to covid-19 inoculation
here at the University Clinic 32 year
old Vera and 26 year old Alexander are
looking for help
they've suffered major health problems
since their covet inoculations a year
ago experiencing a variety of symptoms
that are making life difficult
it's Alexander's first time in Marburg
he had to wait eight months for an
appointment
the Outpatient Clinic for postvoc is
overrun
it's my third time here and look at how
the readings have changed it could be
down to the medication
what are your main problems
neurological problems are still the main
thing for me the pain in my hand and my
nerves
and my immunity
and my hand is still misaligned since
last winter
they have an idea where it comes from
the nerves
they did a biopsy on my nerve tissue and
found nerve damage it stayed rigid like
that
[Music]
see before
I definitely didn't have that beforehand
no nerve pain either
after the inoculation I clearly had
something five days later I had vision
problems and dizziness and headaches I
went to the optician and was told I had
blockages behind both pupils to three
cursor to thrombosis and That Was Then
traced back to the inoculation
but in the months after it's now 12
months ago
I got more and more varying symptoms
like dizziness and heart palpitations
when standing up
also nerve pain and pins and needles
nobody believed me then I was dismissed
as mentally ill
I was always told it's nothing
measurable but they did do a biopsy of
my nerve tissue and I hope that with all
cases it's taken seriously and not put
down to being just in the mind that when
someone comes in with numbness the
doctors do a biopsy
foreign
the cause of post-vac syndrome is not
yet known
patients develop varying symptoms a wide
range of factors could play a role such
as undetected illness or infection at
the time of inoculation
The Many Factors make treatment
difficult according to banshifa a
Cardiologist and head of the
post-vaccination Outpatient Clinic
you have to look closely and that's what
takes so much time
and it also makes it so hard for us to
do our jobs here and then convey the
findings
I can't simply tell doctors so and so
who's just phoned me give me your
instructions and we'll do it just like
that
me
I listen everyone is more than welcome
to observe our work here to come and
look at our lab methods
[Music]
during the forensic search for causes
and appropriate therapy the employees at
the center for unrecognized and seldom
illnesses are in demand here blood
samples of those Afflicted are broken
down into individual parts and analyzed
we believe that inflammatory processes
can be triggered in some patients
through a covert infection or an
inoculation
by that is we don't yet know
that's what we're in the process of
researching
it's improving here you see here that
it's dropping in many patients
there are surely also genetic factors
that play an individual role how
everyone has thousands or hundreds of
thousands of genetic variations in their
genomes and those are perhaps triggered
more in one person than in another
it's not so easy to analyze that ad
hocus
these are scientific questions that can
take a while to answer you can't cure or
understand an illness just like that in
one or two weeks it can take years some
people work their whole life to identify
the way an illness works
two years after inoculations began there
is still a lack of clinical studies on
the cause and treatment of side effects
we also need clinical algorithms so that
patients no longer remain in diagnostic
limbo
in advance
and we need treatment centers where they
know what to do
has at least brought her cardiological
problems under control
but her medical Odyssey continues both
neurologically and immunologically
after filming she was diagnosed with
damage to her immune system
which requires further treatment
Vera and Alexander who must first see if
his new medication helps him decide to
remain in contact they intend to compare
notes and support each other
[Music]
over 15 of the world's population live
with a disability a majority of them in
poor countries where Health Care is
lacking
these people were hit particularly hard
by the lockdowns with even the simplest
aspects of daily life posing big
problems
ew report Julius mogambua met up with a
blind man in uganda's capital Kampala
[Music]
got to messimi is passionate about music
and also about law
he wanted to study to become a lawyer
but then covid-19 hit
[Music]
he was due for an admissions test when
the university moved the applications
online
which left the blind man in the dark
establish the working rules because
everything was done online and for us we
were green about online I missed
pre-entries for mercury
as I had applied
um I couldn't come because by the time
we were supposed to come
they closed that transport and
schools were closed as well so I
couldn't be successful in law
to massimi is now studying to become a
teacher but he hasn't yet fully adapted
to e-learning
I had to look for someone to to help me
upload my examinations and sometimes
issues could happen and my exams could
not
upload truly load my performance if I'm
to compare my performance in year one
and here two here two is better because
yeah two we had no such issues we're
doing exams physically
at his university
signs with measures to prevent the
spread of covid-19 could be seen across
the campus
to massimi felt left out
it became an uncomfortable experience
I wasn't able to
identify those areas where water is to
wash my hands
unless I had maybe someone say come and
wash your hands that's when I could
realize but in most cases after entering
campus I got my guide like after three
weeks because you choose a guide for
yourself
and before
in those three weeks before getting a
guide even navigation the mobility
wasn't all that I could get lost
to different places
in the community tomasime faces related
challenges like accessing public
transportation
he says that this worsened during the
pandemic when the government shut it
down
there were no exceptions made
even for people with disabilities who
rely on support from others
we were restricted even when you're with
your guide you're moving on a border but
that they want you to be on separate
Buddha borders but at the end of it all
you get yourself lost
border borders uganda's motorbike taxis
were his Lifeline during the pandemic
which left him more isolated than usual
for the community members many people
have not understood us
they don't normally socialize with us
so it's very hard in the community about
three percent of uganda's 47 million
population are said to be visually
impaired they are part of a wider global
population of a billion people living
with some form of disability
research shows that during crises the
disabled often suffer most already when
you have a disability you have a budding
of dealing with all the things you may
not be able to do it's some of them are
Mobility some of them are you know with
the education and so with additional
restrictions of not being able to move
not being able to access at least the
little Services you would have been able
to access
was an added burden you know statistics
show that amongst the poor people
uh people with disabilities are the
poorest so if a normal regular Ugandan
lives on a dollar a day then a person
with their disability is even worse
after the pandemic exacerbated the
plight of many guards to massimi hopes
people will learn from it
he hopes for a more inclusive Society
where people like him are no longer
overlooked by their communities
[Music]
moved to Kenya's Capital to find work of
his three children his eldest son
accompanied him but then yakubite caught
covet 19. today we're in Nairobi as part
of our my covet series
foreign
[Music]
I was hearing that lots of people were
dying from covid
even rich people
so when I got it I was prepared because
I thought who am I to survive if even
presidents were dying
people who have everything they need
they have everything to protect
themselves my name is
I'm an electrical engineer in Kenya I
had a covet 19.
I remember it was in 2021 and it was a
Wednesday
I was working and everything was fine
until the evening
that's when I started to feel as if I
had the flu
I had difficulty breathing difficulty in
breathing so I went to a private clinic
to get tested
when I told them my symptoms
they first decided to do a covet test
and when the results came in I was
positive
I was shocked
my eldest son was living with me because
he was studying in Nairobi
so he also had to get tested fortunately
his was negative
I considered checking into a quarantine
hotel but my son would be left alone at
home it was so challenging in the end I
stayed at home and we wore our masks
every day
but I wasn't able to sleep at night
I used to stay awake because I was
afraid that if I fell asleep I would die
well I thought I would go forever
after two weeks I went back for another
test and luckily I was negative
since having covered I've been dealing
with health problems that I didn't have
before up to now
for example now I have problems with
digestion digestive problems that wasn't
the case before covered
work has not been good I have two boys
in college and my daughter is still in
high school it's been very challenging
to earn enough money and that's hit me
very hard
estimated faster after recovering I was
vaccinated for the first time I also got
a second dose as well as the last one
the booster shot
government measures have helped reduce
cases if you compare when people were
not wearing masks to know when people
are you see the infection rate has gone
down drastically
[Music]
do you have a question about covid
our science editor Derek Williams
tackles them based on the latest
research and Analysis
write to him at covert producer dw.com
this week he answers a question from
Susan
what does research currently say about
repeated covid-19 infections
remember back in the early days of the
pandemic when having and getting over
about with covid-19 at least was thought
to have a big upside which was that
survivors for the most part at least
felt
protect it afterwards kind of like the
way I remember feeling after getting my
second dose of vaccine and and then my
third dose of vaccine but now that we're
all swimming in what's being called
variant soup that idea no longer really
holds water I personally know many
people including a couple in my own
family who have had the disease twice
now and a few who've tested positive for
it three times
that shouldn't actually come as a huge
surprise I mean after all the four
coronaviruses that generally cause
cold-like symptoms are able to infect us
multiple times throughout our lives so
reinfections are certainly possible but
how often will they happen in the future
well covid-19 become seasonal like flu
that seems likely though we don't know
how long exactly that process will take
Health authorities do mostly agree that
otherwise healthy people who recover
from covid-19 are generally at low risk
of getting it again for at least a few
months but each person is going to have
a different immunological history with a
disease so it's impossible to really
predict your individual risk and if
immune evasion turns out to happen in
different ways with different
sub-variants experts say you can't
really rule out possibly getting
infected by them even in Fairly short
order Omicron at its sub-variants though
have really kind of thrown a monkey
wrench into what we thought we knew
because they're super infectious and
several look like they're better at
evading immunity than earlier versions
of the virus and and Omicron also
continues to mutate at a pretty fast
pace that ability the experts say could
easily cause numbers to to spike pretty
hard and fast in the coming winter in
the northern hemisphere
when it comes to disease severity upon
reinfection however the news is more
positive most studies I've read show
that when reinfection does happen the
course of the disease in general seems
to be milder
[Music]
residents of Islam in the Venezuelan
Capital Caracas found a new way to stay
in contact despite pandemic restrictions
they came up with the idea of starting a
Rooftop Cinema
the project turned out to be so popular
that it's still going strong
the red brick Shanty homes rise steeply
on the hills of patare in the east of
Caracas
home to Jimmy Perez patari is one of the
largest slums in the world the flat
rooftops here are called Plata bandas
these Open Spaces gained new
significance during the covid-19
pandemic
it's a place on the roof of a house made
with construction materials
in the populated areas the platavanda is
a social space where people celebrate
birthdays 15 years birthdays carnival
activities take place here
the platform the Halls people's memories
it guards a family's most treasured
feelings
the rooftops became the base for the
project cine Plata Banda launched in the
first months of the pandemic it used
Outdoor Cinema to relieve residents
confined to their homes
the events have continued beyond the
quarantines and lockdowns and expanded
to include live music more than 200
screenings have now been held with
several scheduled each month
the project was a reaction to the
increased level of violence and suicide
experienced during the pandemic the
Project's co-organizer and Jimmy's twin
brother Jaime explains the program
there are children films and documentary
films one important film which deals
with the fight against oppression
this is for a population that is living
through trauma and going through the
process of mourning and sadness
also the scars left by Venezuelan social
situation
all of that was projected into our Plata
Banda cinema screen which was welcomed
by the community had generated awareness
what's the level of violence was reduced
as the film ends residents flashed their
lights to applaud and not only for the
entertainment they are grateful for the
connections the rooftop events have
created
sometimes there may be events which I
can't see from my house
we speak with our neighbors who are
watching
and we move to their house and sit
together because they have a big balcony
with a good view
we already knew each other but now we
share more
this rooftop project allows us to share
more have more contact
and now we're more integrated
the pandemic intensified the social
problems which have plagued potato gangs
used the lockdown to step up criminal
activity
pitare known as Venezuela's the most
dangerous place became even more
insecure through Sydney plattabanda the
community reclaimed public space the
organizers say their initiative showed
patari's residence how to take action
where Public Services fail
I aspired to see violence reduced
is the only way if they're adding People
Like Us who take care of important
topics necessary topics then we will be
in appetite without hope and without
future
we aspire to have a more Humane
Community with a better education with a
better opportunity where people feel
useful
and we are showing that without
government without being part of
structures we have demonstrated great
achievement significant and important
achievement for the people for the
community for children for caretakers
and for parents
the cineplata banda team Drive their
equipment to one of the poorest parts of
the giant settlement
where their excited audience awaits
this screening is for the children who
hardly get to visit a real Cinema
donors have signed up to provide food
for kids who frequently go hungry
many parents are without work they can't
take care of their families
there are children who go to bed without
eating
when I started coming here they told me
Glenda I've gone two days without eating
two days without food it's something he
has experienced
they give us a lot and now we're bigger
and stronger
this Cinema project is shining a light
on how a community can come together
even in the darkest moments
that's it for today see you next week on
the covid-19 special when we'll show you
other ways in which people across the
world supported each other during the
pandemic
in a Buenos Aires soup kitchen for
example
thanks for watching and stay healthy
[Music]